I think some of you might have some new  boyfriends or be single are you very in  love my dear I'm very happy he's up to  you amazing so I'm driving lefty how did  you know that he was the guy for you  what makes them amazing you know I'm  very happy as well oh you know  relationship yeah I'm very happy being  someone yes we have seen some being seen  for a while now ed Sheeran just revealed  that he wrote shape of you for you I  think but then he didn't give did you  guys know that that was no we had no  idea I think I saw like something  recently in the press and I was like  that is incredible insight here like who  wants to write for us and placing  approval we love him have you been in  touch could that really happen  Emily came to see our show last and he  did play a few songs with me this one  that he thought would be good for a  billion stay for the next hour  they really good